- So Chuck, what's been
bugging you lately?
- Dorian, Maria, Irma...
- Your ex-girlfriends?
- No.
(laughter)
(smooth music)
- Hurricanes, I get it, I get it.
- How they form is brilliant.
- You know how they form?
- Yeah.
- Okay, okay.
Yeah, I don't know if people know
that each of these low pressure systems
that build up in the South Atlantic,
they each get named alphabetically,
alternating boy name, girl name,
so that's how you know how deep into
the hurricane season you
are, the storm season,
by how far down the alphabet you've gone.
- [Chuck] Wow.
- And so do you think people
know how they're formed?
I can--
- No, go ahead.
- Okay, I need an Earth.
There it goes.
- Oh, well look at that.
(laughs)
Any planet you want is here.
- Yeah, any of the eight planets.
Get over it.
Okay.
So we all know Earth rotates.
- Right.
- And on the equator, they actually rotate
faster than anybody else.
Their speed through space is faster.
- Makes sense.
- 'Cause they make a day's
trip like everybody else does,
but they've gone 25,000 miles,
and anyone else has gone--
- Less.
- Less, all right.
That's fact number one.
Fact number two, let's
throw a low pressure system
in the Atlantic, and you're a puffy cloud.
Which way you gonna go?
- You're gonna push me north.
- Yeah, so all the system
will push you north
towards that low pressure system.
And I'm another puffy cloud north
of the low pressure system.
Which way are you gonna go?
- I'm gonna go south.
- You're gonna go south.
So the low pressure system
attracts all clouds.
- Right, oh wow.
- Calling all the
clouds, so there they go.
Now, if that kept up,
they would just sorta
meet in the middle, but
that's not what happens.
- Hey, what's up?
How you doing?
- That's not what happens because
everybody has sideways motion.
And I'm a cloud south of
that low pressure system,
and I go towards it, but wait a minute.
I have speed that will overtake it,
'cause I'm going sideways
faster than it is.
- [Chuck] Okay.
- [Neil] It'll overtake it to the right.
- Right.
- Now you're above, and
you're headed towards it.
You're gonna fall behind it to the right.
- Oh.
- And that creates a general circulation
of all weather around
a low pressure system,
and that's what we call a storm.
And so Chuck, it probably makes sense
that if you repeat this in
the Southern Hemisphere,
everything is gonna move
in the opposite direction.
So storms in the Southern Hemisphere
actually rotate clockwise,
and that would mean
a storm on the equator wouldn't
know which way to rotate.
- You've got a storm-free zone.
- It's a storm-free zone.
- [Chuck] Nice.
- All right, and there you go.
So Chuck, the fact that
things circulate in this way
with clouds from below overtaking
and from above falling
behind, that was studied
by a guy named Coriolis, and it's called
the Coriolis force.
- Aah.
- So it's not really a
force, but it looks like
there's a force pushing things,
and that's what happens when
you're on rotating surfaces,
and not only that, how do you get a cloud
in the first place?
You need moist air that's unstable,
which means it'll rise.
- Right.
- So if you have moist, rising air,
it's colder up there than down here.
You know that if you've
been in an airplane
and look at the temperature
outside the plane.
- Not very pleasant.
- Not much, it's like 40 below zero,
'cause all the sunlight passes through
our transparent atmosphere,
hits the ground,
and the ground heats the air.
- Right.
- The sun doesn't heat the atmosphere,
except in some very special layers of it.
The sun heats the ground,
the ground heats the air.
- So the radiation of heat back--
- Back!
- Is where the energy's
coming from.
- Correct.
That's what we feel, because that becomes
that back in infrared.
That's how that works.
- [Chuck] Cool.
- Comes in as visible light,
gets re-radiated as infrared.
- [Chuck] Okay.
- Yeah, so, what happens?
So the ground absorbs
it and it re-radiates it
later in the day.
So the hottest time of day
is not at peak heating.
It's a little later when
the ground gives it back.
- [Chuck] Three o'clock.
- Two or three o'clock in the afternoon.
The hottest month of the year is not June,
which has the first day of summer,
the longest day of the year, and that has
the most ground heat.
No.
- Like August.
- Because there's a delay,
the oceans pick up this energy, okay?
This thermal energy, and
it gives it off later.
Later, so wait, when is hurricane season?
- August.
- It's August and September, okay?
Because Earth is beginning to cool down,
but you have this heat source.
- That's still--
- That's still, and it's
a moisture source, and it's unstable.
- [Chuck] Wow.
- So the air rises, makes clouds,
low pressure system gathers, you have
a circulating system,
thus is born a hurricane.
- Hurricane, boom!
- Boom, boom!
- Look at that.
- Now, hurricanes, the lower
the low pressure system is,
the more clouds it attracted, the more
devastating the hurricane is.
The faster it'll turn, everything.
- Look at that.
- Yeah, so that's that.
Now, as it sorta, they can
sometimes make a left turn
into the Caribbean, as
it so devastatingly does
for the island countries there,
or it can go up the coast.
- Right.
- All right, now, if it goes over land,
doesn't have the heat from the ocean,
and so generally they lose their punch.
- Less heat, less moisture.
- Exactly, generally
they lose their punch,
but if it stays along the
coast, it can stay potent.
- Aha.
- And they don't move very fast.
I mean, along Earth's surface, 10 miles,
20 miles an hour tops.
- Right.
- Okay.
That means if you do the math for how long
it would take it to go up the coast,
it can take weeks.
Guaranteeing that--
- But I'm a hurricane,
I got no place to be.
- I got time. (laughs)
- I got time, baby.
- Some place along this
coast, it's gonna landfall
during high tide.
Somebody's gonna get
a high tide hurricane.
- Right.
- And that's bad, because high tide
can be bad enough, but a high tide
that would be during full
moon or during new moon,
that's what I mean by high tide.
Every day has a high tide.
I'm talking about big high tide, right?
Full moon, new moon.
The hurricane hits you
during one of those,
you get extra tidal, you get storm surge
as well as the tide surge.
- [Chuck] Wow.
- And so that can, particularly in the era
of global warming where ocean levels
are slowly creeping up,
you can end up going over
gates and jetties and levies or whatever
is holding back the water.
You can breach that.
Just takes an inch to breach it.
- That's it, flooded the city.
- You can flood the
city, 'cause as long as
the hurricane is there,
you flood the city.
- Get your buckets out.
- But that's what happened
in Hurricane Sandy,
here in New York.
I lost electricity downtown, 'cause they
went over the side wall.
- That's all it was, yeah.
And then the storm surge
was not even a foot.
- But it just has to be
whatever it is above.
- [Chuck] Whatever it is above, yeah.
- That's all you needed above the limit.
Yeah, you got it.
Whole underground parking lots,
cars were bobbing out of the parking lot.
So here we are in hurricane season.
That's what's going on.
- There you go.
Everything you wanted to know
about hurricanes and more,
right there.
- Mm.
- So if you dig Coriolis or hurricanes
or just StarTalk, make
sure that you subscribe
and hit the bell so you
don't miss an episode,
and, if you're so inclined, make sure
that you support us on Patreon.
- And, as always, keep looking up.
(smooth music)